foreign
highnesses
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
Eva Klaus
my dearest Arena
for almost one year now
Ukraine has stunned the world
on that fateful February morning
many predicted that Keith would fall in
a matter of days
but this did not account
for the morale
and the physical courage
of Ukrainian people
dearest Elena you and your people
you have resisted the Russian invasion
and pushed back against the aggressor
Against All Odds
not even Russia's Relentless attacks on
civilians and you have described them
or the Specter of a brutal winter
have shaken your resolve
in this last year
your country
has moved the world and has inspired
Europe
and I can assure you that Europe will
always stand with you
many doubt it
whether that European support would be
so unwavering
but today
Ukraine is a candidate country to access
the European Union
European count
[Applause]
European countries are providing more
and more critical weapons to Ukraine
we're hosting around 4 million
ukrainians in our cities our homes and
our schools
and we have put in place the strongest
sanctions ever
which leave the Russian economy facing a
decade of regression
and its industry starved of any modern
and critical Technologies
there will be no impunity for these
Russian crimes
and my friends there will be no let up
in our steadfast support to Ukraine
from helping to restore power
Heating and water
to preparing for the long-term effort of
Recon reconstruction
and to reaffirm that support
we announced yesterday that the
commission is delivering 3 billion euros
of financial support this is the first
tranche of our 18 billion support
package for 2023 the largest ever
microfinancial assistance to a third
country
this is a strong message
and this will bolster Ukraine's
Financial stability help to pay wages
ensure the running of hospitals and
Housing Services and schools I just want
to say my dearest Elena and I think I
can speak on behalf of this whole and
this audience here we are in it for as
long as it takes and stand by our
Ukrainian friends
[Applause]
and Europe's reaction to the war is the
latest example in how our Union has
pulled together when it matches the most
take energy
a year ago
Europe had a massive dependency on
Russian fossil fuels built over decades
this made us vulnerable
to supply squeezes
price hikes and of course vulnerable to
Putin's Market manipulation
in less than a year
Europe has overcome this dangerous
dependency
We have replaced 80 percent of Russian
Pipeline gas
in parallel we have filled our storages
of course we have reduced our demand
by more than 20 percent in the period
from August to November
and through Collective effort
we brought down gas prices quicker than
anyone expected
from its peak in August this was 350
Euros per megawatt hour
it is now European natural gas prices
down dropped by 80 percent by this month
that is below the levels of before the
Ukraine war
Europe has once again shown the power of
its Collective will
nevertheless
we should be under No Illusion how
difficult these periods first of
pandemic and Then followed by a war are
for our families and for our businesses
and we will have to show the same
resolve as we face up to a collision of
crisis
dear Klaus as your Global risk report
sets it out
we see Rising inflation making the cost
of living and the cost of doing business
more expensive
we see energy being used as a weapon
we see threats of trade Wars and the
return of confrontational geopolitics
in addition
climate change already
comes with a huge cost
and we have no time to lose in the
transition to a clean economy and that's
what I want to speak about
The Net Zero transformation is already
causing huge industrial economic and
geopolitical shifts by far the quickest
and the most pronounced in our lifetime
it is changing the nature of work
it is reshaping the nature of our
industry
but we are on the brink of something far
greater just think
in less than three decades we want to
reach Net Zero
in less than three decades we have to
reach Net Zero
but the road to Net Zero means
developing and using a whole range of
new clean Technologies across our
economy in transport in buildings in
manufacturing in energy
the next decades
will see the greatest industrial
transformation of our times
maybe of any times
and those
who develop and manufacture the
technology
that will be the foundation of
tomorrow's economy
will have the greatest Competitive Edge
so the scale of the opportunity is clear
for all to see
the International Energy agency
estimates
that the market for Mass manufactured
clean energy Tech
will be worth around
650 billion dollars a year
by 2030.
more than triple today's levels
to get ahead of the competition we need
to keep investing in strengthening our
industrial base and making Europe more
investment and Innovation friendly
and that is what investors are looking
closely at in the different markets for
clean tech
here in Europe
we moved first with the European green
deal to set the path to climate
neutrality by 2050. we have cast our Net
Zero Target into law
to provide the predictability
and the transparency business needs
we followed up with our investment
Firepower of Next Generation you that is
our 800 billion investment plan the just
transition fund and other instruments
across the economy
this is unprecedented investment in
clean technology across all sectors of
the green transition
clean tech
is now the fastest growing investment
sector in Europe doubling its value
between 2020 and 2021 alone
and the good news for the planet is
that other major economies are also now
stepping up
Japan's grain trans green transformation
plan aims to help raise up to 20
trillion yen around 140 billion euros
through green transition bonds
India has put forward the production
linked incentive scheme
to enhance their competitiveness in
sectors like solar photovoltaics and
batteries
the United Kingdom Canada and many
others have also put forward their
investment plans in clean tech
and of course
we have seen the inflation reduction act
in the United States that
369 billion US Dollars clean tech
investment plan
that means
that together
the European and the United States alone
are putting forward almost a trillion
euros
to accelerate the clean energy economy
this has the potential to massively
boost the path to climate neutrality but
it is no secret that certain elements
the design of the inflation reduction
Act
raise the number of concerns
in terms of some of the targeted
incentives for companies
so this is why we have been working with
our United States friends
to find Solutions
for example so that EU companies and EU
made electric cars can also benefit from
the invest inflation reduction Act
our aim should be
to avoid disruptions in transatlantic
trade and investment
we should ensure that our respective
incentive programs are fair and mutually
reinforcing
and we should also set out how we can
jointly benefit from this massive
investment
for example by creating economies of
scale across the Atlantic or setting
common standards
at the heart of the joint vision
is our conviction
that competition
and trade are the key to speeding up
clean tech and climate neutrality
and that means
that we Europeans also need to get
better at nurturing our own cleantech
industry
we know that we have a small window
to invest in clean energy and Innovation
and clean tech before the fossil fuel
economy becomes obsolete
so we have an industry at the moment
being challenged by the pandemic supply
chain issues and price shocks we see
aggressive attempts to attract our
industrial capacities away to China and
elsewhere
we have a compelling need to make this
Net Zero transition without creating new
dependency we've learned our lessons
from the fossil fuels
and we know that future investment
decisions will be taken now
depending on what we do today
we Europeans have a plan
a green deal industrial plan
our plan to make Europe the home
of cleantech
and Industrial innovation
on the road to Net Zero
our green deal industrial plan
we'll be covering four different pillars
the regulatory environment
financing
skills
and trade
the first pillar is about speed and
access we need to create a regulatory
environment that allows us to scale up
fast and to create conducive conditions
for sectors crucial to reach the Net
Zero goal that we've set ourselves this
includes for example wind heat pumps
solar clean hydrogen storage and other
topics for which demand is boosted
by our next Generation EU and repower EU
Investments
to help make this happen
we will put forward a new net zero
industry Act
this will follow the same model as our
chips Act
the new net zero industry Act
will identify clear goals
for European clean tech by 2030
the aim will be to focus investment on
strategic projects along the entire
supply chain
we will especially look at how to
simplify and Fast Track the permitting
process for clean tech production sites
in parallel to this Net Zero industry
Act
we will reflect on how to make
important projects of common European
interest the famous ipcis
faster to process easier to fund simpler
to access for small and medium
Enterprises and for all our member
states
The Net Zero industry Act
will go hand in hand with a critical raw
materials Act
for Rare Earth
which are vital for manufacturing key
Technologies like wind power generation
hydrogen storage you name it
Europe is today
98
dependent on one country
China
or take lithium
with just three countries accounting for
more than 90 percent of the lithium
production the entire supply chain has
become incredibly tight
this has pushed up prices and it's
threatening our competitiveness so we
need to improve the refining process and
recycling of raw materials here in
Europe
and in parallel
we will work with our trade partners
to cooperate on sourcing production and
processing to overcome the existing
Monopoly
to do this we can build a critical raw
materials Club
working with like-minded Partners from
the United States
to Ukraine
to collectively strengthen Supply chains
and to diversify away from single
Monopoly
this is pillar one speed and access
through the Net Zero industry Act
the second pillar of the green deal
industrial plan will boost investment
and financing of cleantech production
to keep European industry attractive
there is a need to be competitive with
offers and incentives that are currently
available outside the European Union
this is why we will propose
to temporarily adapt our state aid rules
to speed up and simplify them
easier calculations simpler procedures
accelerated approvals for example simple
tax break models
and with targeted eight
for production facilities and strategic
clean tech value chains
to counter relocation risks from foreign
subsidies
but
we also know that state aid will only be
a limited solution which only a few
member states can use
now to avoid fragmenting
of the single Market
and to support the clean tech transition
across the whole Union
we must also Step Up EU funding
for the medium term
we will prepare European sovereignty
fund as part of the midterm review of
our budget this year
this will provide a structural solution
to boost the resources available for
Upstream research Innovation and
strategic industrial projects
but as this will take time
we will look at a bridging solution
where it is most needed to provide fast
and target targeted support
and to support this we are currently
working hard on A needs assessment so
the second pillar is
funding and state aid
the third pillar of the green deal
industrial plan
will it be developing the needed skills
to make this transition happen the best
technology is only as good as the
skilled workers who can install and
operate it
and with a huge growth in new
technologies
we will need a huge growth in skills and
skilled workers in this sector
this will cut across all we do whether
it is regulation or Finance
and will be the priority of our European
year of skills
the fourth pillar
will be to facilitate open and fair
trade to the benefit of all
for cleantech to deliver Net Zero
globally
there will be a need
for strong and resilient Supply chains
our economies will rely ever more
on international trade
as the transition speeds up to open more
markets and to access the input needed
for the industry
so we need an ambitious trade agenda
including by making the most for example
out of the existing trade agreements for
example with Canada or for example with
the United Kingdom with which we are
trying hard to sort out our difficulties
we're working on concluding agreements
with Mexico chile New Zealand and
Australia
and to make progress with India and
Indonesia
and we need to restart a conversation
regarding the mercosur agreement
because international trade
is key
to helping our industry cut costs
create jobs
and develop new products
but
by the same token
where trade is not fair we must respond
more robustly
China has made boosting clean tech
Innovation and Manufacturing a key
priority of its Five-Year Plan that's
good
it dominates Global Production in
sectors like electric vehicles and solar
panels which are essential for the
transition
but competition on Net Zero must be
based on a Level Playing Field
China has been openly encouraging any
intense energy intensive companies in
Europe and elsewhere to relocate all or
part of their production
they do so with the promise of cheap
energy low labor costs and a more
lenient regulatory environment
at the same time
China heavily subsidizes its industry
and restricts access to its market for
European Union companies
we still need to work and trade with
China especially when it comes to this
transition
so we need to refocus
our approach on de-risking rather than
decoupling
this means using all our tools to deal
with unfair practices including the new
foreign subsidies regulation
and we will not hesitate to open
investigations if we consider that our
procurement or other markets are being
distorted by such subsidies we want to
cooperate we want to work together
climate change needs a global approach
but it has to be a fair approach and a
Level Playing Field
ladies and gentlemen
the story of the clean tech economy is
still being written
and over the years I've been coming to
Davos
I have heard many times that we are on
the cusp
of a period of creative destruction
that the economist Joseph schumpeter
spoke of
his idea that Innovation and new tech
replaces the old leaving the old
industry and jobs behind
in many ways this Dynamic applies to the
clean tech revolution of today and
tomorrow
but I believe
if Europe gets it right
the story of clean tech economy can be
one of creative Construction
with the right support and incentives
for companies to innovate
with the right focus on skills and
people
with the right environment to make the
most out of our world leading Innovation
capacity
Europe already has everything it takes
Talent researchers industrial capacity
investment
and Europe has a plan for the future
and this is why I believe
the story of the clean tech economy will
be written in Europe thank you very much
[Applause]